[Music]
can you hear us
yes
hey uh joining us uh yeah joining us uh
of course from from the blaze uh the
host of the news and why it matters and
uh also somebody i think we've shown
shown up a couple times on a couple of
prime time videos oh
yeah sarah gonzalez joining us today hi
sarah yeah thanks thanks for having me i
i do make the occasional cameo in the
alex uh videos now it's funny because
everyone all automatically assumes that
i'm like his wife or his girlfriend
and they're like way to go alex you got
him and i'm like we're just friends
that's it
so hey it's crazy are they rioting in
the streets because abortions are
completely illegal forever for everybody
forever according to the news
yeah they they just banned abortions in
the whole country um i you know it's
fascinating to me
looking at over the weekend most of the
violence that i saw i don't know about
you guys most of the violence that i saw
did come from l.a and from california
and i'm like
what the hell is wrong with you people
literally nothing changes for you
nothing changes for you you will still
be able to get an abortion up until the
the very minute presumably that the baby
uh it goes through the magical birth
canal that somehow turns it into a human
and it is delivered like you guys will
nothing will change for you
what is your problem oh wait you're just
really stupid
yeah i mean well you know i it's it's a
matter of i i think stupid i agree with
that it's also a matter of the level of
propaganda
like
like it's it's everything you turn on
it's like are they gonna take
interracial marriage away and gay people
are gonna be sent to the moon clarence
thomas is clarence thomas gonna vote to
overrule interracial marriage right come
on
the funny thing about that too is number
one
clarence thomas was the only person who
brought that up the only justice who
brought that up so presumably even if
that was on the table
like he would be the only one in favor
of that and he doesn't last time i
checked he doesn't make the decisions on
the supreme court all by himself but
number two it's like these people can't
fathom the idea that their rights don't
come from the government
and so they they i think that they think
that the supreme court is just like this
establishment that grants them rights
and doesn't grant them rights and
doesn't even understand like no if
clarence thomas says he thinks that the
same sex marriage case was ruled
incorrectly all he means is that you
don't have a freaking constitutional
right to it like they they don't
understand the difference because they
just think that the government is there
to allow them or disallow them to do
something they can't comprehend anything
else
well no that's true
because it's it's
this this is we were just talking about
this actually right before we went to
break and
it's also this mentality of
they they kind of build they kind of
build their own prison right like it
happens to them all the time they build
their own prison like we were actually
we were actually showing you know
first off the the amount the amount of
the amount of of
of people that did we're doing stuff
like this was amazing this is gina
darling from g4
uh if men were able to get pregnant this
would uh
this would have never been up for
discussion lol [ __ ] this backward ass
[ __ ] an hour later
oh wait pardon my wording not sure what
proper wording this is oh wait uh but i
guess people born with male reproductive
organs if that's not correct please
educate me sorry that came off as
transphobic you're like oh god you guys
are in hell and you did it to yourselves
damned if you do when you dance if you
don't and my thing is you know with bro
versus weight overturned it's like for
me i think the biggest takeaway is
seeing all these leftist women now just
suddenly be so miserable because up
until a couple days ago i remember them
being all smiles and sunshine and uh
it's been very very weird uh paradigm
shift to see leftist women suddenly
miserable it's like dude if roe versus
wade didn't get overturned you'd be
[ __ ] trying to burn down a courthouse
in portland anyway for some for some
perceived you know [ __ ] something
that happened to you so it's like i
don't you know whatever it's also really
funny to see like like on the screen we
have right now women that definitely
can't have a baby anymore being like
this really hurts me why does this hurt
you how does this hurt you this doesn't
this doesn't this doesn't affect you and
and also did you brought europe clarence
thomas in this machine the amount
of complete like it felt like they did
all they call the alt-right bad the
things that they were calling clarence
thomas i mean the n-word the uncle uncle
clarence
i saw him get called the n-word yeah so
much and i was like what's going on and
i was like i don't think i've ever heard
any any of the so-called all-right
people exactly like i mean it was
machine gun n-words on twitter and i was
just like what is what's happening
yeah so so you hear that from the left
uh whenever a black person does
something that they don't like and so
you so they're using the n-word right
right and
really when you think about it uh the
pro-life position would be that uh hey
actually we want more black babies to be
born we don't want more black babies to
be aborted in new york than are actually
born like we want
all the black babies born so who's the
racist party here which one which one is
racist because you guys are calling uh
black people the n word and we're like
hey can we just have more black babies
being born that would be pretty cool if
they got to be born and not uh killed by
their own mothers they do tend to uh
really try to downplay the underlying
fact that
it's it's a lot of work and it's
disproportionate it's disproportionately
that right i mean it's yeah there's not
a there's not a lot of like nuclear
family jewish homes that are like well i
guess you're gonna have to get it aboard
it yeah it just doesn't happen like this
which margaret sanger is like this was
my dream i love this oh yeah marcus
hanger is having a party in hell in my
opinion there's not a lot of there's not
a lot of catholic mexicans being like
well i guess you're just gonna have to
have an abortion like
that's the other thing the fact that
they go this is really going to hurt
them not hispanics not the hispanic vote
not the black vote either if you really
think about it i mean if you talk if you
want to talk about like look what
happened in texas man they they flipped
the place that went for how many points
for
for biden they flipped it to like 11
plus because
the problem is is that these things
these things are great because you know
the reason like for example like a
mexican a mexican family comes to
america because i want the i want to be
able to work i want to be able to
provide for my family and i want them to
get the best education in the world and
then they go
oh yeah here's the thing though you
can't afford an apartment we're going to
teach your kids uh that they could be
whatever gender they want and they could
abort them if they want without talking
to their family like wait wait i didn't
sign up for this and people go i'm not
going to vote for that why would i why
would i vote for people that want to
eradicate my children you know
yeah yeah well that's what i kept trying
to uh i mean i guess maybe it was stupid
of me to try to warn the left of this
but i'm like you guys if you guys keep
pushing you are going to lose the
hispanic vote because traditionally
hispanics are very as you pointed out
like
family oriented uh obviously very
catholic and very pro-life um you know
just some degrees like you shouldn't
even be taking birth control oh yeah
yeah they're hardcore
yeah and of course like their their kids
and their family their kids are
everything to them and they're not
really down with the whole lgbt stuff
like yeah i'm not gonna make a blanket
statement about like uh homophobia but
like i'm just that's just that doesn't
resonate with hispanic families
well particularly hispanic men and so
like you guys keep pushing this you're
going to lose the hispanic vote and i
think that's what we're seeing let me
explain something i i am cuban so i know
firsthand
i know firsthand the machismo number one
and and and and the and the nope not in
my house mentality and i think that that
that overtakes any politics that the
other thing that i said is
if this if the ro if the roe v wade
thing people go like oh man this
happened now this this really sucks
because midterms i go no this is the
perfect time to do it and here's why
you could you could change your vote on
nuanced things when everything's good
right when everything is so good you're
like well you know the economy's great i
have a good job i could vote depending
on what the abortion thing is because
that's the most important thing but when
people don't have money right when
people can't get baby firmly when people
can't get food when people can't drive
drive anymore because gas is seven
dollars a gallon people like yeah no i
get it and i'll give i don't i'm not
gonna even argue about this this isn't
important to me or 99 of people because
the other thing is like condoms aren't
going anywhere birth control isn't going
anywhere plan b isn't going anywhere
like and what's the worst thing that
happens i mean the only thing i said is
the upside is maybe the gas prices go
down if enough women have to drive far
enough for abortions they'll keep
complaining about it and maybe they go
down a little bit
no i was um i was reading actually uh
when we taped my show today i was
reading
insider the outlet insider did they
talked to like young women i guess it
was gen z so they were born after 1996
and they were asking them how they felt
about this new decision and the answers
were just ridiculous i mean you had like
a 19 year old who was like
well
i'm just i'm really i mean i've had to
really think about having not having as
much
casual sex anymore and you know it
really just it's made me dial that back
down and i'm like oh my god you poor
baby that really sucks for you that
you're not having as much casual sex
whatever will you do with yourself uh if
you can't go out and sleep with all the
men like oh no i feel so let me shed
this tear really quickly for you oh okay
there it is it's gone yeah
it's like it's gross this is look white
liberal women are the absolute worst
that we have to we just thank you
shut down on all white liberal women
until we can figure out what the hell is
going on with them they're like probably
on antidepressants
and birth control and all of these like
mood altering substances that screw with
their hormones and then you get this
kind of crap it is it's like it's
it's sickening especially as you know as
a a woman to watch all of these women
who claim to like they want to represent
womanhood and you know that they talk
about feminism and all of these things
and i'm like please stop i could
actually could you identify as something
else because i don't want you to
identify as a woman anymore now i'm
pro-trans yeah just go identify
something else i don't want you but but
that's exactly the point it's like you
guys are you guys are his you're being
hysterical number one
you you always your behavior isn't what
i would call a boss [ __ ]
when you're mailing your period blood
the supreme court like it's always like
yeah you know i take i i do everything
you know i i i i work so hard we're
gonna shatter the glass ceiling but i
swear to god if i don't get free birth
control i'm gonna burn down the supreme
court i swear to god i'm like what are
you doing
it's just so it's so frust like it's
like um i my friend eric july he's he's
on my show a lot of the things that he
okay so he's like
anarcho-capitalist is what he calls
himself you know libertarian minded and
he always says that you can't reason
with someone who came to their position
based out of like
that they came to
by way of emotion and it's so true it's
like these people are not you can't
reason with them you can't read just
like the the the pro-abortion people
that we're talking about that are like
you know out in dallas i went to a
protest to see if anything was going to
pop off and they're like twerk
they finished they concluded their
official protest by twerking for
abortion
what the [ __ ] is that okay
that's what i missed that's amazing you
just don't understand these new zoomers
and how they this is how they
express their um just you know injustice
and rage
this is crazy this is how they speak
yeah you got to speak truth to power and
sometimes you do it by make you know
making that uh you know what pop for a
real you know what
i'm trying i'm trying to clean it up you
know i know i know you're a big you know
you're you're kind of a big deal
compared to us so and i'm trying to i'm
trying to keep it at least you know just
just at r rated yeah i'm trying we're
not going nc17 yeah but um but yeah no
seriously listen to that cardi b song
yeah
yeah yeah but it's like these people
they have no idea what why they're doing
what they're doing because they've not
reasoned anything out they like it's
impossible to reason with them they're
just
making all of these decisions all of
these snap judgments just based on
emotion
it's crazy